[Música]
méxico- indemnizará a los familiares de
los mineros que quedaron atrapados en
una mina de carbón el pasado 3 de agosto
hace ya cuatro semanas que no se sabe
nada del grupo de sus seres queridos han
venido denunciando negligencia en el
rescate el gobierno dijo que las
operaciones continuarán
en colombia la jurisdicción especial
para la paz que investiga y juzga a los
actores del conflicto armado en el país
ahora investigar a diversos crímenes
cometidos de manera conjunta por la
fuerza pública y grupos paramilitares la
medida se da en respuesta al pedido de
cientos de víctimas
nuevas protestas en haití cientos de
personas salieron a las calles de puerto
príncipe para rechazar el aumento de la
delincuencia que azota al país el alto
costo de vida esto en medio de la
inflación más alta en 10 años según el
banco central
hola bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en france 24 los
saluda andrés meza muñoz empezamos en
mexico el gobierno dijo que entregara
una indemnización a los familiares de
los 10 mineros que quedaron atrapados
así casi un mes en una inundada mina de
carbón en el estado de coahuila las
autoridades siguen extrayendo agua del
pozo y todavía no se sabe nada del grupo
mientras sus seres queridos denuncian
negligencia los detalles nos los
entregaba previamente nuestro
corresponsal en ciudad de méxico -mario
carbonell
así es si bien el presidente no se ha
referido a los mineros como ya
fallecidos pues queda implícito al
hablar de esta indemnización y dar los
detalles de la misma él ha dicho que
ésta no será convencional que será una
indemnización extraordinaria no sólo por
el agravio de haber perdido a sus
familiares sino por la situación de
pobreza en la que se encuentra esta
gente es por ello que será una
indemnización más allá de lo que marca
incluso la ley hay que señalar que el
acuerdo de indemnización es con las
esposas de los mineros pero no todos los
familiares están de acuerdo algunos
otros como padres madres hermanos
no están convencidos ellos quisieran que
les entregaran primero los cuerpos de
esos seres queridos y ya después hablar
de indemnización sin embargo este fue el
acuerdo con las esposas e incluso se
levantará un memorial aunque el
presidente ha señalado que este memorial
será una vez que hayan hallado a los
mineros y que el rescate continuará en
estados unidos el presidente joe biden
condenó los ataques que ha recibido el
fbi a raíz del allanamiento que realizó
a la residencia del ex presidente de
donald trump en florida el pasado 8 de
agosto el ex mandatario es investigado
por supuestamente haber sustraído de
manera inapropiada una serie de
documentos de la casa blanca que
contenían información clasificada tanto
trump como sus seguidores calificaron la
situación como una cacería de brujas con
motivaciones políticas
bardem defendió a las agencias federales
es repugnante ver los ataques contra el
fbi que amenaza la vida de los agentes
del orden público y sus familias por
simplemente cumplir la ley y hacer su
trabajo
miren quiero decir esto lo más claro que
pueda no hay lugar en este país ningún
lugar para poner en peligro la vida de
las fuerzas del orden ningún lugar
ninguno nunca punto
me opongo a desfinanciar la policía
también me opongo a desfinanciar al fbi
pasamos a colombia la jurisdicción
especial para la paz creada para
investigar y juzgar a los actores del
conflicto armado en el país anunció la
apertura de un nuevo caso y ahora
investigará crímenes cometidos por
integrantes de la fuerza pública y otros
agentes del estado en complicidad con
paramilitares y terceros civiles y que
no están incluidos dentro de los otros
casos abiertos desde 2019 según lage hay
un total de 15 mil 710 víctimas de
hechos atribuidos a integrantes de la
fuerza pública
56.500 dos paramilitares y 280 a otros
agentes del estado están justificaciones
contra insurgentes agrupa los hechos que
guardan relación con las motivaciones
denominadas con la fiscalía como la
radicalización de la lucha
contrainsurgente y estigmatización de la
población civil
detrás de estas motivaciones estaba
también la pretensión de consolidar el
control territorial mediante la
victimización hacia civiles sospechosos
de pertenecer o colaborar con las
guerrillas de las farc de la ln y del pl
después de reestablecer sus relaciones
diplomáticas los presidentes de colombia
y venezuela están planeando su primer
encuentro así lo anunció el embajador
colombiano en caracas armando benedetti
gustavo petro y nicolás maduro se
reunirán en octubre luego de tres años
de tensas relaciones entre ambos países
la última vez que dos mandatarios de los
países vecinos se vieron frente a frente
fue en 2016 en puerto ordaz territorio
venezolano cuando juan manuel santos y
maduro se reunieron para hablar sobre
una disputa que provocó el cierre de sus
fronteras
el presidente de brasil gay bolsonaro
atizó la atención con chile al insistir
en que sólo decía la verdad cuando
insinuó que su homólogo chileno prendió
fuego al metro durante el estallido
social de 2019 el mandatario brasileño
restó importancia a que el gobierno de
chile convocará a su embajador en
santiago como forma de protesta y
aseguró que fue solo una forma del que
gabriel boric demostrar su descontento
el presidente de chile acaba de llamar
ahora a su embajador su forma de mostrar
su descontento ya sea que exagere con o
no
y no deje de decir la verdad la
constituyente de chile va en contra de
lo que quiere cualquier país democrático
ese problema es de ellos y es de ellos
derecho pero el ciudadano de allá tenía
el apoyo de un tipo aquí en brasil
buscará que durase trabajadores
argentinos volvieron a las calles para
exigirle al gobierno de alberto
fernández una renta básica universal las
protestas fueron en buenos aires y en
otras ciudades del país y no han sido
las primeras es que la clase trabajadora
se queja de los efectos de la inflación
que en julio fue la más alta en los
últimos 20 años el instituto nacional de
estadística del país se explica por
ejemplo que mientras el salario mínimo
está en 334 dólares una canasta básica
de alimentos para una familia de dos
adultos y dos niños cuesta más del doble
al estar en 817 dólares
90.000 millones de dólares se portan en
nuestro país se van a exportar este año
y sin embargo se padece hambre porque
porque esa riqueza quedan concentradas
en un grupo muy reducido de empresas
transnacionales por eso es que hoy en
todo el país desde jujuy hasta tierra
del fuego marcharemos en las puertas de
los puertos y de las grandes empresas
responsables de la fuga de capitales
para exigirle al gobierno que priorice
las necesidades de los sectores
populares y no siga subordinándose al
mandato del fondo monetario
internacional- cientos de haitianos
volvieron a salir a las calles a
protestar contra el aumento de la
delincuencia y el alza de los precios al
consumidor al menos una persona murió y
11 resultaron heridas durante las
protestas en el oeste del país los
manifestantes exigen la renuncia del
primer ministro ariel en hey informe de
kimberley zambrano
vuelve al caos en las calles de haití
neumáticos quemados en las calles gases
lacrimógenos y un creciente descontento
social son los síntomas de que la crisis
no se dé en el país caribeño cientos de
manifestantes en puerto príncipe-
denuncian el alto costo de la vida el
aumento de los precios de combustible y
la inseguridad culpan a las autoridades
de la situación y exigen su renuncia
la razón por la que estamos en la calle
es para exigir la salida del primer
ministro ariel a rey y sin condiciones
decimos no al costo de vida excesivo oa
la inseguridad y no a la escasez
artificial de combustible en las últimas
semanas los habitantes han tenido
problemas para encontrar combustible
dejando a algunos sin poder trabajar
en este país los proyectos de igualdad
no aplican tanto como el proyecto de
muerte estoy en las calles para decir no
al secuestro no al caro costo de la vida
y no al aumento de los precios de los
combustibles manipulados por la
burguesía siempre estar en las calles
para denunciar este tipo de cuestiones
[Música]
la violencia y los secuestros han
aumentado en puerto príncipe y las áreas
cercanas en los últimos meses mientras
los asesinatos productos de la guerra
entre las pandillas por el control
territorial asciende a este julio de
2022 a 934 según naciones unidas la
pobreza también se ha profundizado
algunos productos básicos como el arroz
han cuadruplicado su precio y a
principios de este mes el banco central
de haití informó que la inflación había
alcanzado su nivel más alto en 10 años y
cerramos con información de la nasa la
agencia espacial estadounidense confirma
una nueva fecha para el lanzamiento de
la misión arts emmys la operación se
llevará a cabo este sábado 3 de
septiembre cinco días después de que la
misión se suspendiera debido a una fuga
de combustible en el motor del cohete
sls el más potente creado por la agencia
el programa arte que tiene como objetivo
principal llevar de regreso al hombre a
la luna en 2025
hasta que este informativo gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]